sometimes watching a movie just isn't
enough you also want to eat that movie
and that's why there's movie recipes
[Music]
today we're gonna show you how to make a
Man of Steel gingerbread Superman cookie
that is a gingerbread Superman cookie
that tastes exactly like the movie Man
of Steel start with a store-bought
gingerbread dough because we don't want
to get too original here roll the dough
while singing bits of Russell Crowe's
songs from lame is because Crowe is
carrying Man of Steel serving as the
dough that holds whatever drama exists
together add chili powder because that
is serious business just like the film
spread on a layer of mayonnaise because
this movie is the whitest pink thing
you've ever seen
even Laurence Fishburne is playing a
white guy scream at the dough in a
derogatory manner will come out as angry
as sod cut the dough into two giant Man
shapes bake at 350 for 15 minutes while
the cookies bake punch everything
finally once the cookies have cooled
decorate them so they look like Zod and
Superman rip off the head of the Zod
cookie for no reason and in one fluid
motion
flush Superman down the toilet garnished
the pieces of Breaking Bad meth for the
Kryptonite that doesn't really exist in
this movie but maybe should have and
enjoy mmm the opposite of fun
[Music]